today on the matt walsh show another man
involved with drag queen story hour has
turned out to be a suspected pedophile
this should not surprise us at all we'll
talk about why also five headlines
including the father who was sent to
jail for calling his daughter a she
also a man is a step closer to being
crowned miss usa that's exciting
and the teen vogue editor who is now
canceled for offensive tweets that she
sent out a decade ago nobody is safe
anymore
and our daily cancellation will deal
with the women's uh
ncaa basketball players who are
complaining that they aren't being
treated as equal to the male players but
should they be treated as equal we'll
talk about that in a lot more today on
the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome again to the show remember if
you're listening to us on itunes
right now make sure to subscribe if
you're watching on youtube make sure to
smash that like button
jab that notification bell annihilate
that subscribe button
if you're having our transcripts
delivered to you on um you know
carrier pigeon or horseback messenger
make sure again to subscribe however you
subscribe to that
and i will continue to harass you with
these demands until i am rich and famous
beyond
my wildest dreams now we begin with an
entirely unsurprising story but one that
is no less worthy of our attention the
daily wire
has the news here says a wisconsin
children's court judge who previously
headed up an lgbtq
organization that fundraised for drag
queen story hour among other programs
was arrested
tuesday on tentative charges of
possession of child pornography
brett blaum was taken into custody by
special agents with the state division
of this according to the milwaukee
sentinel by the way the state division
of criminal investigation following an
investigation into multiple uploads of
child pornography
through a kick messaging application
account in october november 2020.
the wisconsin department of justice
reportedly began an investigation into
blam
after receiving a tip through the
national center for missing and
exploited children according to the
complaint which also alleges that blom
shared child pornography with other kick
users through private chats and
messaging groups
on 27 separate occasions this is a judge
also
acting this way the complaint lists
descriptions of the videos which are
both graphic and disturbing some of the
videos involve toddlers
and other very young children blom the
journal sentinel reports was elected to
the court in the spring of 2020
defeating incumbent milwaukee county
circuit judge paul dodinski
in that contest the state democratic
party donated more than ten thousand
dollars to blom's campaign
obama offered himself as the progressive
alternative to dodinsky
before then blom served on the city's
board of zoning appeals and also as the
full-time
head of the cream city foundation an
lgbtq active
activist organization that promoted drag
queen story hour in milwaukee
drag queen story hour is just what it
sounds like drag queens
reading stories to children in libraries
schools and bookstores
that according to the creams cream city
foundation a website which promoted the
events in 2019
they also said that drag queen story
hour captures the imagination
and play of the gender fluidity of
childhood and gives kids glamorous
positive and unabashedly queer role
models
alright so that's the story there there
are so many disturbing aspects to it
not the least of which is the name of
this organization which has dedicated
itself to bringing cross-dressers
and children together cream city
foundation i'm not going to speculate on
that at all
beyond that the very idea of drag queen
story hour is itself disturbing in a
deep and visceral way
but as i said it's not surprising to
find a child predator associated with it
it's also not the first time that such a
discovery has been made
in just the city of houston alone two
registered sex offenders were found to
have been reading stories to children
while dressed in drag as part of drag
queen story hours in the same year that
was in 2019.
other drag queens you know may not have
been registered as sex offenders as far
as we know but their behavior raises
serious questions nonetheless
behavior such as the drag queen who goes
by the name sasha soda
and who wore a mini skirt which exposed
his crotch
as he read to children or behavior like
the drag queen
at a different story hour who laid on
the floor and let children lay on top of
him and there's photographs of that
or behavior like this watch
there's funny little dances from
fortnite does anybody know any of the
dances from fortnite
oh then you are a credit to your
community
but most of all michael likes to twerk
now does anybody in this room know how
to twerk
okay but it's quite important to the
story so i will just give you a very
quick demonstration
all you need to do is you just stand
with your feet sort of shoulder width
apart like show
okay i'll show i'll show you at the side
so you'll get better views
and you crouch down into this sort of
position here so your thumb sticking out
don't be taking this all in and then you
just move your butt up and down like
that
and that's twerking
now if there was ever a time for a
literal
pitchfork mob to show up it's when a
drag queen is giving twerking
demonstrations to a room full of
five-year-olds
instead the adults sit and laugh and
enjoy themselves even the fathers
and i use that term loosely but this is
the kind of behavior that
you know may have been a warning to us
or how about behavior such as
uh dressing in drag and reading to kids
you know just that alone even without
the added bits of pedophilic
degeneracy the very act of a man putting
on women's clothes
in order to go and read or speak to
children
that itself raises serious questions
questions like what possible good reason
could there be for this
what possible justification could there
be is there conceivably a
valid reason for a man to say to himself
hmm you know
i'm reading the children at the library
today better go throw on my mini skirt
and padded bra
the answer to all these questions is
obviously no not only no but hell no not
only no but
or hell no but call the cops this
should be illegal drag queen story hours
are
and have always been a transparent in
your face effort to groom and sexualize
children
they're not even hiding it clearly
that's why these programs exist that's
the goal of everyone involved with them
there's no other conceivable point or
purpose
you heard it in the cream city
foundation's uh description of drag
queen story hour
they're trying to you know encourage
gender fluidity play
now drag is is essentially burlesque but
with men
not essentially that's what it is if it
was a female burlesque performer all
all dolled up hired to come and read the
children as part of the
burlesque story hour program think about
that burlesque story hour
if that was the case then everyone would
agree that it's completely insane and
inappropriate
though in the age of wap perhaps we
wouldn't even agree on that anymore i
don't know
we should be able to agree at least that
there are many good reasons to read
books to children
but there can't be any good reason to
hire a burlesque performer to do it
the only reason to bring her in for the
job would be to try to normalize
burlesque to kids make it seem appealing
desensitize them to it otherwise known
as
sexualizing them it's no different no
better
certainly no better when the performer
is a man so then
why is drag queen story hour a matter of
controversy even on the right
you know what's the controversy over
should there not be
universal condemnation of it at least
among conservatives we know that the
left has lost its mind and it saw a long
time ago
but why are even people on the right
reluctant to criticize this kind of
thing
or at least reluctant to admit that it's
a big deal i mean it's a big deal when
this is going on all across the country
this is
widespread all across the country how
the hell is this happening in our
country
why are so many conservatives that won't
admit that or don't want to talk about
it well because
they've been so beaten into submission
so cowed so
tamed and domesticated by our cultural
overlords that they think it's bigotry
to criticize
anything that the lgbt lobby does or is
associated with or supports
now they don't like it they wouldn't
bring their kids to it i hope
they probably prefer this stuff doesn't
exist but they don't want to say that
too loudly
for fear that words ending in ism and
phobia will be tossed at them
well let me be the first to say i
absolutely have a phobia
about children being abused and
sexualized i have a phobia about that i
do
i'm bigoted against it i discriminate
against it i hate it
this is my hate speech targeted at it
hate is not always a bad thing it's
often a good thing in fact
hate can be a good thing very good thing
necessary
hate is is a necessary part of love
if you love something or someone you're
gonna hate anything
that harms that person or that thing
and hate is especially important in a
culture full of so many things
worthy of our hate drag queen story hour
is certainly one of those things
and we just cannot be afraid to say it
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
before we get into our five headlines
here i want to tell you about our
sponsor my
bookie you know it's it's i think it's
great there's so much
in the world right now that might stress
you out certainly stresses me out
it's good sometimes to unplug a little
bit from news and politics
and focus on something that's fun only
fun fun for fun sake
and that's what my book is all about
march is here and madness has officially
begun
a different kind of man it's a good kind
of madness it's time for you to shoot
your shot and score big on the non-stop
action
with my bookies select the winners from
63 tournament games in the my bookie
bracket
contest for a chance at ten thousand
dollars in cash prizes and it's only a
dollar to enter that's all you gotta pay
it doesn't matter
whether you're filling out multiple
brackets betting the national
championship winner simply looking for
player and game props
my bookie has you covered sign up today
at mybookie.ag
and use promo code walsh to secure a
deposit bonus up to a thousand dollars
that's promo code walsh to claim your
first
deposit bonus you don't want to miss out
on this college ball nba and nhl no
matter the sport
no matter the minute my book he puts the
action in your hands
with in-game live betting and with
choices from thousands of lines and odds
you can turn any game day into payday
bet anything anytime anywhere
with my bookie well you know i'm um not
much
into body shaming i'm a little bit into
it
but not much but anyway bill de blasio
got the vaccine yesterday
and um he put out we got a picture up
here
on the he you got to see this this he
put out the picture of himself getting
the shot
and you can see it there and i mean my
god
those arms can i even call those
withered things arms he's literally
built like gumby
he looks like a stick figure my
four-year-old my draw
he looks like he stole a nine-year-old
boy's leg and used it as a prosthetic
arm
he he looks like if if if if elmo
had gigantism disease
his arms are like pool noodles covered
in skin
i have i have actually seen better
muscle definition on an infant
and my point is here's why i'm bringing
this up uh because those are some
those are some weak ass arms but this
guy was defying his own
coveted restrictions to go to the gym
like everyone else in new york wasn't
allowed to go he had the gyms all to
himself
and you'd expect at the least he would
come out looking kind of buff after that
but what was he doing in there
lifting weights by proxy was did he hire
some guy to lift weights for him and he
hoped that he would
sort of uh inherit the gains through
osmosis
good lord and this only you know proves
my point um
that there's a story that came out last
night about andrew cuomo
and this is another supposed to be
another controversy by andrew cuomo and
it's supposed to tell us i think it's
supposed to
make us hate andrew cuomo even more but
it has the opposite effect for me
apparently according to reports now um
another scandal is that andrew cuomo
at his house during a party or something
he had a dart board
with uh bill de blasio's face on it and
they were taking turns throwing darts at
bill de blasio's face
and i have to say maybe andrew cuomo
isn't so bad after all
based on that um
on in other vaccination news that was
all just a long way for me to to roast
bill de blasio for having weak arms
that's because you know what that's the
one thing on a man
you know that that is though i will
judge you on that
as as a man especially if you're bill de
blasio okay
other vaccination news dr sanjay gupta
had some bad news on cnn he says that
the virus
it might learn how to sidestep the
vaccine which means that you still have
to wear a mask
and i guess it means that you have to
wear masks forever
because the vex because the the virus is
going to get around
the vaccine and it's also going to get
around your first mask which is why you
need a second one
but here's what the good doctor had to
say if somebody has gotten both vaccines
uh for madeira and pfizer or just the
one for j j
and two weeks have passed why does that
person need to wear a mask if they go in
public
well you know if the um if you look at
the science overall
you know you have to sort of determine
what level of evidence are you willing
to sort of
you know make these decisions on it
makes a lot of sense i think that if
it's just the the wild type virus that's
circulating the one that we've been
talking about for the last year you take
the vaccine it should reduce the viral
load that you could potentially carry
make it unlikely that you're infected
and even less likely that you could
transmit it to others
but i think there's two points that keep
coming up one is that there's still a
lot of virus out there
so you know when you have that much
virus out there could you still
actually be exposed and even though it's
unlikely become an inadvertent carrier
but the other and and at some point when
we get to low enough
level which is a few thousand cases per
day not several you know not
40 or 50 000 cases per day you could say
at that point the likelihood of someone
being exposed is so small
we could start to not worry about masks
there's another point just quickly jake
people who are vaccinated they get
exposed to the virus
the virus learns then how to sort of
adapt
and mutate now to a vaccinated person
some some ways by
exposing vaccinated people to the virus
you you could start to inspire
more and more mutations which is
something you don't want to do
okay so what so don't get the vaccine
then
they don't bother getting it what what
what is the message supposed to be they
are really trying to
i i it's like they really are trying to
discourage people from getting the
vaccine
if you're if you're anti-vaxx this
supposedly is a pro-vax person
and on cnn they don't like the anti-vaxx
crowd
but you couldn't ask for a more
effective
and compelling and convincing anti-vaxx
message then
even if you get it your life's not going
to change
why bother in that case
and that raises a lot of questions why
are they trying to why are they
actually trying to discourage people
from from getting the vaccine
because what you're hearing there is is
simply nonsense
we i don't think we have the clip but uh
rand paul senator rand paul grilled
fauci yesterday in a hearing and rand
paul is great
at this you know he was he was grilling
um the uh
the former health secretary of
pennsylvania trans person about
about we played that club a couple weeks
ago grilling on on the issue of
um the trans indoctrination of kids and
kids being drugged and mutilated
so oh we do have the clip do we have
okay okay well here here's rand paul um
talking to fouchy about the masks and
vaccines and actually bringing some real
science and some real facts
to the foreground let's listen what
study shows significant reinfection
hospitalization and death after either
natural infection or the vaccine
it doesn't exist there is no evidence
that there are significant reinfections
after vaccine in fact
i don't think we have a hospitalization
in the united states
after the two-week period after the
second vaccination
yeah you have a death in the united
states you're not
hearing what i'm saying about variance
we're talking about
wild-type versus variance and now
what proof is there that there are
significant reinfections with
hospitalizations and death
from the variants none in our country
zero well because we don't have a
prevalent of a variant yet we're having
one
can i finish we're having 117 that's
becoming more
dominant policy based on conjecture
yeah it's this see this is this is a
scientific line of questions and this
goes on
for a lot longer than that if you
haven't watched the full exchange it's
really worth doing and
and that's what rand paul's great at
this i like rand paul
a lot um he doesn't he doesn't get
really any traction when he runs for
president i think he should get a lot
more traction than he does i don't agree
with
a lot of what he says because he's more
a lot more libertarian than i am but uh
in with this kind of thing he's very
good at this and um
but this is a scientific line of
questioning which is what
what's the evidence we don't want to
hear
maybe it could be this it could be that
that's not enough
we shut down society based on maybes and
could bes and
let's shut down society and uh we'll
shut it down for a year
to be safe you know better safe than
sorry
and then we'll wait for the evidence to
come in so we're gonna shut down ahead
of time
and then wait to see if there was any
reason to have shut down in the first
place
that was the strategy from the very
beginning voucher want to contin wants
to continue doing that
because he doesn't understand or does or
just
does not care about the human cost of
lockdown shutting down schools all of
that doesn't care
he's not affected by it he's doing great
he's getting paid a lot of money is
probably the best year of his life this
past year
and so all the other human suffering
means nothing to him
so it's very easy for him to say well
yeah we'll keep the measures in place
and we'll see
check back in a year get some more
studies in there
rand paul's point is there's no evidence
to support this telling people to wear
masks
or to stay socially distanced after the
vaccine
what is the evidence to support you
saying that
answer well we don't have any there
could be some out there somewhere we
haven't found it yet
all right well then we're gonna simply
ignore you
all right number two um from the daily
wires is on tuesday the father of a
biological girl who believes she's a boy
turned himself into a canadian court and
was subsequently taken to jail
after the attorney general of british
columbia issued an arrest warrant
for contempt after the father had
insisted on referring to his daughter as
his daughter
and used the pronouns she and her god
forbid
robert hoogland from um surrey british
columbia
has a 14 year old daughter in february
2019 the supreme court
of british columbia ordered that the
girl received testosterone injections
without obtaining parents like i said
14 years old
this is four years before this this
child is considered an adult
able to make adult decisions
14 certainly under the age of consent
anywhere in the western world as far as
i know
can't consent at 14 by the law you can't
consent to like anything
without without your parent involved
except this
except injecting foreign chemicals into
your body
to try to change your body
in in profound and permanent ways
the the long-lasting permanent side
effects of which
we don't even fully know yet
um so it says canada ordered that the
girl received testosterone injections
without obtaining parental consent the
federalist notes that the court also
declared that if either
of her parents referred to her using
female pronouns or addressed her by her
birth name
they would be considered guilty of
family violence
canada has lost its mind completely
well the entire western world has but
canada is a little bit there's a few
train cars up ahead of us on the crazy
train when she was in seventh grade the
girls
school urged the girl to see
psychologist dr wallace wong
who recommended the girl should begin
taking cross-sex hormones at 13.
hugeland cited his daughter's alleged
history of mental health issues and
refused to give permission
doctors at bc children's hospital
decided that the girl should receive
testosterone injections
and um and now fast forward a little bit
legally he's not even allowed to refer
to his his own daughter as a daughter as
a girl he's arrested for that
and if you're living south of the
canadian border you're living in america
and you think
they're crazy up there that's never
going to happen here oh it'll happen
here that this this is happening here
this will happen they've already laid
the groundwork for it lay the groundwork
first
through the rejection of biological
science the rejection of objective
more uh reality and morality
and then by saying that it's you know
it's it's hateful
to use biologically correct pronouns
when referring to someone
it's an act of hate
well if that's the case then it's all
it's only so long before they say well
there need to be laws in place to
protect
you know gender confused people from
hearing the correct biological pronouns
and this this again shows why it is so
important for us to
to not go along with this it is not a
small issue
the gender stuff in general as you know
i believe and have always said
not at all a small issue this is a
central issue in the culture
but the pronoun piece of that
it's very very important that is a hill
worth dying on
and you don't even have to die because
i've been fighting on that hill for a
long time and i'm still kicking
but that's a hill worth defending
once you go along with that it's over
and there are more and more again
more and more people on the right who
who even
you know suppose right-wing media
publications you see this more and more
that start using
the preferred pronouns in their articles
and that sort of thing
this this is a matter of reality i'm not
going to go along
with a lie i won't do it i can't
morally i can't
that's the stance we all have to take
it's not
you're not trying to hurt anyone's
feelings you're not being aggressive
about it
no something is being demanded of you
you're not doing this i'm not doing it
i didn't choose to have this discussion
i'm going about my life going about my
day
using correct normal language
and now i'm being told that i have to
use language
that does not signify what i'm actually
trying to convey
so something is being asked of me that
is unreasonable
all i'm doing is saying no i can't go
along with that unreasonable demand
number three here's uh some big news a
man has just won
a female beauty pageant and one step
closer now to being crowned miss usa
which is also something that will happen
here's a local news report about this
let's watch
it's a first for one major local beauty
pageant a transgender person
is now the reigning queen kim passoth
spoke with her and
kim she won the miss silver state that's
the biggest preliminary competition
for the miss nevada usa pageant yeah
that's right john
cataluna enriquez who is transgender has
won
transgender pageants before and she's
entered cisgender competitions
but this is a monumental win she will
now compete for miss nevada usa
the state pageant leading to miss usa
and miss
universe pageants that were once owned
by donald trump
and two of the most coveted crowns in
the pageant world usa
[Applause]
cataluna enriquez loves almost
everything about pageants
the glitz the glamour and now her new
crown
[Music]
from a pageant that not only welcomed
her but embraced her
the silver state competition was a great
experience to me it was honestly
a celebration of womanhood and diversity
and this celebration of being your true
self
so there you go big achievement we're
told a celebration
of the true self which exactly is
exactly what it isn't the opposite of
that
and then you have the women who you see
there they have they have to pretend
not only is this title being taken away
from
a woman given to a male um but the women
have to pretend to be excited about it
you know it's not if you're if you're a
woman it's it's not enough you can't you
can't
merely go along with it you have to be
excited about it
a man takes the beauty pageant crown
and we're it'll happen this year next
year we're very close to a man being
crowned
miss usa all the major beauty pageants
gonna go to men
um men have already won women of the
year and all that kind of stuff so that
that's gonna happen but
if you're a woman you have to be excited
about it so they take that
they'll come into the locker room take
the
the
you know all the athletic achievements
now you can't only stand there and allow
it to happen
that's the first step but the next step
is you have to smile you better have a
smile on your face and you better be
applauding
when all this is taken from you that's
the message from the
you know woman supporting left
where they care they care so deeply
about women's rights
of course the people that are demanding
this of you as a woman remember the
people demanding this
they care deeply about you as a woman
and your rights they care so much about
it
all right it's from uh if number four
from e.t online it says angelina jolie
claims she has proof of alleged domestic
violence against brad pitt
new court records reveal in new court
documents that were filed under seal
on march 12 the actress alleges that
she's prepared to offer proof and
authority
against pitt regarding her claim of
domestic violence during her upcoming
divorce trial why did i choose this
story to read
about angelina pitt or angelina jolie
and brad pitt in their divorce
their divorce uh trial i'm i'm not sure
why i chose that one
we're gonna move on uh okay number five
here's one that i do care about alexi
mccammond has
stepped down this is from newsweek has
stepped out from her newly appointed
position as editor of teen vogue
after several conde nast staff members
complained about offensive tweets that
recently resurfaced
love them with those tweets resurface
resurface always means
as if they bubbled up to the surface on
their own you know
no someone went and dug for them and
brought them brought them to the service
through a willful act
she was due to start as editor-in-chief
of teen vogue on march 24th
and now she has stepped down now these
are tweets alexi mccammon's
tweets that are so offensive
these tweets from 2011 and she was
how old was she she was 17 years old
when she sent these tweets up
in high school and now as a 27 28 year
old woman
she's being punished for that she lost
her job
um what were those tweets so let's see
in 2011
when she was 17 mccann uh mccammon
tweeted
uh first she tweeted out done by an
asian hashtag
what's new i guess she meant in school
so
she was out done by nate i'm not exactly
sure what that refers to and she also
tweeted
now googling how to not wake up with
swollen asian eyes
and then a third tweet that was so
offensive
when she sent it out at the age of 17
she has to be fired for it third tweet
said
give me a 2 out of 10 on my chem problem
cross out all of my work and don't
explain what i did wrong
thanks a lot stupid asian teaching
assistant you're great
and then some of her old tweets used
slurs for gay people as well
she's apologized for this multiple times
uh
they they first quote unquote resurfaced
in 2019 she apologized for them then
uh and then when she was offered this
job at teen vogue
prestigious publication she was
forthright about the fact that these
tweets
are out there and she apologized when
applying apparently
and then when they came out again a
couple weeks ago she once again
apologized
she's just been apologizing nonstop
for these basically innocuous tweets she
sent when she was 17
and she still gets fired for it now this
is a very this is this is a difficult
thing
as a conservative when you see this kind
of story
because this is a this is a leftist
journalist
someone who's very much a part of the
canceled culture
someone who you know if this were
happening to me
there's no way she would come to my
defense
if it were happening to you alexi
mccannon is
mccannon is not coming to your defense
she will be part of the pitchfork mob
trying to destroy you she's gonna be
part of the cancel mob
she'll join in with them so are you
going to defend someone who doesn't
defend you
what's more when someone who is part of
creating this mob has the mob turn
around on them
are you going to step into the middle of
it and say no not her
when she's forced to take a dose of her
own medicine are you going to try to
knock it out of her hand to protect her
no i mean i'm not going to do that i'm
not gonna waste my time defending
her for those reasons also for the
reason that she apologized
it it would be more difficult for me to
decide whether the defender or not
if she had not apologized but as you
know my policy is i don't care if you're
on the right or left
if you're getting canceled for something
and you apologize
there's nothing i can do for you i don't
think there's anything anyone can do for
you there's nothing anyone else can do
for you if you're not going to defend
yourself
and if you're going to admit guilt
basically
and and cave to the mob then what what
i'm not going to defend someone who
isn't even going to bother
i'm not going to put more effort into
defending someone than they will put in
defending themselves
unless we're talking about a child or
some true innocent victim who's not
capable of defending themselves
but she is not a child so many reasons
why
why the not really worthy of defense
here and yet
so we put that to the side
but at the same time we can acknowledge
that this is completely crazy
you know 17 years old 10 years ago
is is there anyone who would dare
step up to the plate and claim that when
they were teenagers
they never said anything that would be
considered objectionable
to people today or even people back then
when you were a teenager
is there anyone who would dare now if
you
if you were lucky enough if you were
fortunate enough to be a teenager
before social media existed or at least
before it was
as ubiquitous as it is now then thank
your lucky stars for that thank god for
that i mean really thank god for that
but just because it wasn't documented
don't pretend that
you never said it that you never said
anything objectionable when you were a
teenager
really in a sane country which we don't
live in the same country but if we lived
in a sane country
we would um we would all agree that
certainly anything you said you get you
get a free as an adult
you get a free pass for pretty much
anything you said as a teenager
because you were a teenager and i would
extend it further than that i would say
i mean really 25 and younger
your brain isn't even fully developed
until you're 25. this is one of the
reasons why i think we should move the
voting age and we should move a lot of
these ages up
to past 25 for that reason
i mean you're quite literally not all
with it yet uh you know
you don't you don't have your full
capacity to be the mature discerning
adult
that hopefully you you eventually turned
into
and also as adults you know i i think
maybe we could even extend it further
than that and say
if you're in your 20s or 30s um
ten years ago may you may as well be a
lifetime
may as well been a different person ten
years ago
because you grow and change and evolve
so rapidly
during that time now like the difference
between a 45 year old and a 55 year old
is not that great
difference between 55 and 65 not that
significant
the difference between 35 and 25 is
enormous
enormous even more significant probably
than the difference between 25 and 15
if if you are a growing and maturing
person i mean it should be an enormous
difference
so a sane country would recognize that
acknowledge that and say look
this was so long ago it's a different
person
who cares really who cares
and and in general there should be a
statute of limitations
there should be a statute of limitation
on taking offense at something i believe
no matter the age of the person or how
long ago was if someone said something
and you weren't bothered by it at the
time when it was said
you don't get to circle back around a
year later or five years later or 10
years or 20 years later and say you know
what actually i'm offended by that
you don't get to do that now you could
say well i wasn't aware of it when it
was said originally okay then no harm no
foul
you survived this offensive thing was
said you didn't even know about it you
were living your life
totally unencumbered by it
that's even less reason for you to take
offense now
so those are all those are all i think
important points to make
and again in a sane country that's how
we would look at these things
with that said as far as alexia mccammon
goes
she did bring this on herself by being a
part of this mob and now it turns on her
and she is a she is a black woman she is
a left-wing
black woman and even like a year ago
that would have been enough to inoculate
her from this
but that's not the case anymore nobody
is safe now nobody is safe
and people like lexi mccannon they're
part of the reason why nobody is safe
okay let's go now to reading the youtube
comments we got a couple here dr jones i
don't know if he's a real doctor says
matt i'm not sure if you know this but i
think ben used your set for his show
today just letting you know because i
feel like
that's something that would annoy you
hashtag justice for matt well i will say
uh yes yes how dare ben use my site
i know that he used it didn't ask my
permission so
how dare he i could almost tolerate it
if not for the fact
that um when i sat down for my i don't
know if you noticed this i don't even
know if you can see it on my desk
anymore but i have my fake
daily wire family my two my two pictures
of the
the daily my assigned friends and family
from the daily wire that was put on my
desk when i first started
here but when i sat down this picture
was gone and this is the picture of the
guy
and a girl on a tandem bicycle and it's
a very important picture to me
and when i sat down it was it was
nowhere to be found
i guess ben found that this photograph
of my
assigned friends so offensive that he
put it somewhere
it disappeared and but now it has
reappeared
so uh cameron says totally agree with
not using abbreviations the other day my
co-worker said wtf
at which i told him that if he just said
the actual words it would be less
syllables which he had not considered
yeah it's bad enough when people
abbreviate things by putting in
the e sound at the end as we've talked
about using
internet abbreviations is really
reprehensible
now i will con i don't know why i'm
confessing this but i believe in full
transparency and i'm an honest person
i did a few days ago find myself
actually saying to someone in
conversation
btw and and i i hated my
it came out of my mouth i don't know how
it came out and i said it
and i immediately hated myself i would
if there was a window i would have
jumped out of it
um like a like to preserve my own honor
so i'll admit that
but even so everyone else who does it
deserves to be canceled
um dog-faced pony soldier
says matt who do you feel is a worse
person
cardi b or meghan markle that's a good
question i don't think there's any way
to rank them
that's impossible that really is
splitting hairs and finally egg sandwich
now there's a great name
says cat should be inside matt
well you see this this is really why
punctuation is so important
uh so important because i think what
they're saying is cat should be inside
comma matt addressing me
but there's no comma so instead it says
cat should be inside matt
and i have no further comment on on that
whatsoever aside from
remember your commas people listen you
spend a lot of time on the internet we
all do
it just makes no sense for you not to
secure
yourself why what are you doing what
kind of choices are you making with your
life you got you got to make sure you're
protecting yourself
uh and offering yourself some protection
from those bad actors out there
especially now the irs
issued an urgent warning about a new
scam to steal the electronic filing
identification numbers
from tax professionals over emails cyber
criminals can use this information to
file fraudulent tax returns
tech professionals should be aware of
the latest phishing scam but individuals
should also take steps to protect
themselves
tax season is stressful enough you don't
want to add identity theft on top of it
it's important to understand how cyber
criminals
and cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day we put
ourselves and our information at risk on
the internet
in an instant a cyber criminal could
harm what's yours your finances your
credit
so many other things good thing there's
lifelock lifelock helps detect a wide
range of identity threats like
if your social security number is for
sale on the dark web if they detect your
information is compromised
then they'll send you an alert and if
something does happen god forbid they
also have identity theft
restoration specialists that are there
to help you out nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can
keep what's yours with lifelock identity
theft protection
join now and save up to 25 off your
first year by going to
lifelock.com walsh that's lifelock.com
walsh to save 25 off and you know the
wait is finally over after inviting her
to join the daily wire
on election night the one and only
candace owens is joining our team
finally with her new show candace
you may have heard of candace when she
uh slammed harry styles on twitter for
wearing a dress by saying bring back
manly men you may have heard of her
through kanye west when he said that she
he likes the way she thinks or
heard of her recently with the stuff
with cardi b she's always got everyone
talking and
every week candace is going to keep that
going she's going to talk about
politics news and the hottest trends you
can come see why the left doesn't want
candace to have a platform she's opinion
opinionated and authentic premiering
today march 19th
candace will be exclusive to daily wire
members if you aren't a member yet
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
and use code candice for 25
off love or hater you won't want to miss
it go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25 off
let's get now to our
daily cancellation
today we're going to cancel the women's
ncaa march madness tournament now i know
what you're thinking
there's a women's march madness
tournament yes i had the exact same
thought when i was made aware of the
sexism controversy surrounding the
women's tournament
and the accommodations that the female
athletes are receiving in comparison to
the men so here's the the usa today
here's usa today with news on the
controversy it says the ncaa
acknowledges
the discrepancy and amenities between
the men's and women's basketball
tournament on thursday after images
posted social media drew significant
backlash picture surface thursday
showing the stark differences and gifts
that were presented to women's
basketball players compared to men's
stanford sports performance coach ali
kirschner posted photos of the
facilities inside the indianapolis
bubble
compared to the san antonio bubble wnba
star sabrina
ayun sku a big big fan of hers
last year last year's national player of
the year in ncaa women's basketball
fumed over a poor display in the weight
room tweeting
quote women's ncaa bubble weight room
versus men's weight room
thought this was a joke wtf what is this
to all the women playing in the march
madness tournament keep grinding
the picture showed the plentiful options
in the internet in an indianapolis
weight room compared to a small rack of
dumbbells in san antonio
ajo wilson who plays for the las vegas
aces and
the wnba another player that i
am not only aware of but a huge fan of
tweeted
the weight room situation is beyond
disrespectful then sedona price who
plays for oregon
posted a tick tock calling out the
disparity between amenities writing
intercaption it's 20 21 and we are still
fighting for bits and pieces of equality
okay now the end of the naac the ncaa
there we go
has apologized and pledged to fix the
problem but to give you the visual
if you're watching on the daily wire
youtube right now here is sedona price
with her tick tock video complaining
about this discrepancy in the way that
the men
and women are being treated let's watch
i got something to show y'all
so for the ncaa march madness the
biggest tournament
in college basketball for women this is
our weight room
let me show you all the men's weight
room
now when pictures of our weight room got
released versus the men's the ncaa came
out with a statement saying that it
wasn't money
it was space that was a problem let me
show y'all something else
here's our practice court right and then
here's that weight room
and then here's all this extra space
if you aren't upset about this problem
then you're a part of it
well then i guess i'm a part of it
because i'm not that upset i have to say
it's not on my top 20 list of concerns
in my life right now
is that the women ncaa players
don't have enough weights in the weight
room
see it's it's one thing if you simply
asked for better equipment you know
that's fair i won't begrudge you that i
have to admit the first time i saw that
video
uh and i'll admit this myself the first
time i saw that video
and i saw the women's weight room set uh
i did
burst out laughing hysterically i can't
help it don't don't blame me the problem
is that it's just extremely funny
to me but i can understand why the
ladies might want a bit more to work
with than a rack of five pound dumbbells
at least
get some 10 pounders on there for god's
sake and and a couple of yoga mats
the problem though is when you lecture
me
that i need to be upset about women
basketball players not having all the
exercise equipment they want
and you tell me that i'm a part of some
greater societal problem and you demand
equality see
that's where the problem comes in and
i'll tell you why that's a problem
there is no equality between men's and
women's sports
especially men's and women's basketball
the equality doesn't exist
any effort to make them equal or to
treat them equally
is absurd here's a simple fact the men's
ncaa tournament generates
billions and billions of dollars the
women's tournament according to the wall
street journal
doesn't turn a profit it loses money
so you have on one hand a sport that
makes billions
on the other a sport that makes nothing
actually earns negative
it has to be propped up kept afloat put
on artificial life support
men's basketball keeps women's
basketball in existence
the very existence of women's basketball
is a favor
that men's basketball is doing for it
because it can't survive on its own that
again that's just a fact to give you one
isolated example ohio state
the men's program earns over 10 times as
much revenue from ticket sales as the
women
and that's only ticket sales 10 times as
much
now why is that why does men's
basketball both on the collegiate and
professional level
completely trounce women's basketball
and revenue well because
nobody cares about women's basketball
nobody watches it
nobody goes to the games almost nobody
anyway and what this means is that
the vast majority of the people
pretending to be upset about the unequal
treatment of female athletes
also themselves do not watch the women's
games or have any real interest in them
so they're standing off to the side
basically saying yeah you know i don't
give a damn about this i think it's
boring as hell but uh sure yeah
it's an outrage if this thing i don't
care about and that nobody else seems to
care about
isn't treated the same as the thing i do
care about that everybody else cares
about
it's absurd see i would have a lot more
respect for sedona here
if she had said listen i know we aren't
as important as the men's side
and i know that the men are keeping us
in business um and i
i really appreciate that by the way
thanks guys for for allowing us to exist
as a team
because we wouldn't if not for you but
we'd still really appreciate some better
accommodations
i'd respect that i'd be on her side
but instead we get lectures and speeches
about equality
and when you come at me like that it's a
non-starter
any discussion of equality is an
onstarter men's and women's sports are
not equal
will never be equal it should not be
treated as equal and the thing is you
might be mad you might want to be mad at
me for saying that
but you can't really be mad because
you're not watching it either
so yeah you're part of the problem with
all that said
i support women's sports i want women's
sports to continue to exist
and the greatest existential threat to
the continued existence of women's
sports is not a lack of workout
equipment
it is rather of course the intrusion of
males into those leagues
that's why i'm fighting to keep males
out anyone who is not fighting for that
or is instead actively fighting to get
men into these sports
can't pretend to be upset about unequal
accommodations
when you get your way women's sports
won't exist at all
that's the real threat and it stems from
the same confusion that leads people to
be upset about girl basketball players
not being treated the same as guy
basketball players
the confusion is in the belief that men
and women are the same
interchangeable not different in any
significant or fundamental way
but they are different they are not the
same they are not equal
as equal means same and that's why the
women's basketball tournament
isn't owed the same treatment or the
same accommodations
but it's also why women athletes are
owed the basic protection of keeping men
out of their sports
and that's how this all breaks down and
those who don't understand that
are canceled i guess i also said at the
top that the whole women's tournament is
canceled
that may be a bit harsh on second
thought you know also kind of redundant
nobody's watching it anyway
and far be it for me to cancel something
that i just learned existed
five seconds ago so instead we'll
we'll keep the cancellation more broad
than that that's another favor that i
will do
for the ladies you're welcome
and we'll leave it there for the day and
the week hope you guys have a great
weekend we'll talk to you next week
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021. hey everybody this is andrew
clavin host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin